I am
are rare
snow
we tried
my name is alejandro olmedo I am
an opera singer I have sung in 64
countries around the world
jay the mentor and that boy with llorís to
get over the age
people say it is absurd to sing
opera here in callao but  it's
incredible because people like it
every monday here in shanghai very
restaurant we sing at 7 at night
operate as always we invite singers
and valid sopranos the senators come
and we have a good party here and
we have a wonderful time
before i am here in this
restaurant was in russia singing for
several years during five hundred
and forty-seven concerts throughout russia
that in about 150 cities i started singing
here because this
and i was doing nothing and suddenly they
no longer had a concert written
for him
alejandro sanz lovers of the sun it
will be  We are going to leave your sinuous friend
without,
the origin of the plan will be fine, I already told you, only
this year, look for a guy alone and of the hell,
I believe in o  another year and say old phishing
to my toral Korean brother and he is my best
friend number one I am very happy very
grateful for mister jean that I
have the privilege of singing and
living from the opera of my singing arrives at the
stand for two of  my many
engines from all over the world
all analyze and see them I make
me when I sing in a great theater I sing
with passion with the truth with all my
heart and when I sing a restaurant the
same one and wherever I have to
sing with everything